serait ce encore les chasseurs de
pokémon on va monter jusqu'à la porte
noire pour récupérer les les indices
suivants pour ensuite avoir les
coordonnées finale de de la cache
a priori ce nom les deux amis sont en
quête d'une cache une petite voix
dissimulés dans les hauteurs de besançon
et pour la trouver il faut chasser une
créature bien réelle cette fois notre
patrimoine
donc là s'est scindé le chiffre des
unités de la date à laquelle la porte
fut érigée massue bisontin depuis une
vingtaine d'années je pensais déjà
connaître bien besançon depuis la
découverte du lot ka-shing il ya un
nombre à je redécouvre en fait des
endroits que je pensais connaître et
puissent pour certains endroits des
endroits que je connaissais pas les sons
gates ans et s'il va continuer
tranquillement leur chasse aux indices
dans la cathédrale saint jean car
pendant ce temps à 25 km de là on vient
tout juste de découvrir une cache
celle ci a été posée par la commune de
rio d'un sentier découverte sur la
thématique du ferroviaire du patrimoine
des gouffres doc l'idée c'était vraiment
par le géocaching de faire découvrir ce
sentier de rando d'une grande qualité
pour l'office de tourisme le géocaching
permet de faire découvrir le territoire
un public plus large
on est situé entre vesoul et besançon
donc un territoire qui est très
accessible
mais du coup une notoriété qui est pas
énorme et qui est un peu grignoté par
besançon on va dire à besançon justement
nos deux chasseurs continuent leur quête
aux indices trouvés la rose de sages
auront noté eux qui est le nombre de
pétales de la rose
et cette fois c'est la bonne les
coordonnées gps sont complètes
il est temps pour le dur de débusquer la
cache dans convoité dans cette boîte
on va trouver des petits objets pour
faire des échanges ça s'appelait bien
aux enfants on trouve un livret dans
lequel on va noter notre passage
c'est la fin de la balade on est content
d'avoir découvert des dévots endroit
deux ans entre les nous aussi